this is session number nine
and uh
if if all goes well
uh we'll have 10 11 and 12 later on
today
uh actually as I look at the schedule
for today we're talking about things
that are most uh
most system dependent uh these are the
things that are most concerned with
people in the audience I imagine because
they're the things where you're going to
have to be responsible to make it work
on your own system on the other hand the
uh the percentage of
things that I have to cover to the
things that are in the book is
um uh is is much higher which means that
I can I can go slower today yesterday I
was taking I was I was taking huge parts
of tech and just waving my hands and
saying because it's sort of like this
today we're taking small parts of tech
the small system dependent parts and we
can go over them slowly and leisurely
make sure that everyone gets a thorough
understanding of what's involved
um
and file names is the is the agenda for
this hour starts in module number 428
I think we'll be able to uh keep the
lights on uh all hour as far as I know
it's for the TV people back there
um now
uh
here we're getting into the subject
which is which makes portable software
the the most difficult
because operating systems different
operating systems uh
um differ in the way they want to refer
to file names
um
I thought once that maybe we should just
say that in as someone's writing in Tech
and wants to say input from a file or or
name a font uh some file that text
should have its own language for file
names so that it could be independent of
systems but there was just no way that I
could do this and make it make it right
a person who's who's using Tech as a as
one of his uh uh or her favorite tools
on a system we'll definitely want to
call file names by the by the same
conventions that are used for other
programs that are used in that system
so um we have to live with the fact then
that there will be there will be
programs written in Tech
that are going to include syntax that
isn't going to be possible on other on
other installations of tech just in this
place where we refer to names of fire
um now
um
there should be something that works
everywhere namely if we if we have a
file that the name is entirely composed
of letters
then every version of text should be
able to do a reasonable thing with it so
I mean if I if someone says in
input paper
should refer to some file called paper
that I think will be able to handle on
all on all installations of tech
the the
strange thing happens that what if it's
somebody else's paper and so we have to
say input
uh
as seen for somebody else paper
on one operating system or we have to
save paper
uh you know SE slash paper on another
system and paper
bracket
one comma SC on another system and so on
and there's lots of other different
kinds of bracketings and things that are
used in order to locate things in file
file servers and on networks and various
things
um then it's going to be different
everywhere and it depends on the system
dependent version of tech two parts
these names and to come up with
something sensible about them
now so in you know but I want to try to
have a little bit of uniformity in all
of this and uh and so I tried to write
text
82 in such a way that that the system
dependency would be factored out into us
into a small number of of routines that
could be caused that could be called in
a system-independent way
um
and this this is uh an attempt then to
get as much portability as as we could
given the fact that we that uh that we
couldn't be completely
um uniform across all systems
now
um
I'm sure that if I interviewed the
people in the audience I'd get another
long longer list of of possibilities
certainly I see the guy from MIT right
right here and uh they have uh a really
strange sex a bunch of conventions okay
um now uh we can talk about I mean for
example on their on their system you
give two names separated by spaces and
then paper uh
is one of the ways to work it on that
system and one of the things Tech likes
to say is that a space is a delimiter
after a file name
so if if the name of the file is going
to include spaces then they should put
quote marks before and after
um and and and uh take spaces out inside
of there for example some kind of a
scheme like that would should be
implemented but it should also be
consistent that somebody who did who
does this can be comfortable with the
idea that it'll also work at MIT even
the reason that MIT is and Stanford tend
to be more different is because they
started first
and the conventions persisted over over
many years and the reason this whole
thing is in such a mess is because
computer scientists haven't considered
that file naming was was part of real
computer science and and uh never really
paid much attention to the problem I was
always left office being as as being
some something uh for hackers or
something and it was never but it's
never considered as a scientific problem
um and so we had this proliferation and
things the same applies to it to a
almost as much a degree just in all
input output in general
computer scientists have tended to work
on what you do inside the machine once
you've got it in there and before you
put it out but uh but it but input and
output never was was given a very clean
solution in the
uh in like in languages like algol and
so on where the where the the best uh
language designers have really have
really sat in committee meetings they
didn't they just didn't tackle input
output uh
because they didn't
somehow I think it didn't meet
their taste for what was in what was an
important problem at the time should
have been but it but it didn't
so um
so we have this problem let's see how we
how we can approach it now the thing
that the thing that Tech uh uh 82 wants
to impose on uh is is at least one kind
of thing that that a filing consists of
three parts
um it consists of the main part
paper and it consists of an area part
which which indicates what area this
this uh this might be on what uh a
location within a large file directory
and there's an extension part
now it seems to be that true that when
using these systems that we've been
talking about where that that can make
sense to have relate have have related
files and in the uh in the systems we've
been using here we we relate the files
by giving them the same name but
different extensions
so a person running paper would write a
file called paper.tech for example
and then he could he could expect as a
result of his run to get paper
dot DVI
for his output the DVI file
paper.err
for the transcript file of his session
containing uh his error messages and
more information and diagnostic
information
um
if somebody
has a font called basic I mean a a
format uh or macro package called
basic.tech and you input that to any
text you would expect to get out basic
Dot fmt
for the format
when we write a program in web Tech we
have tech.web tech.ch for the change
file we compile it into
tech.pass.com or something for the
Pascal file and tech.pool for the string
pool file some kind of this this idea of
having uh the having a family of names
with extensions on it seems to work
reasonably well with other operating
systems and it could be you don't need a
dock for that if you don't like a dock
but in the examples in the tech manual
it's they're we're going to use a DOT to
indicate that now the area is is the or
file directory or whatever you call it
telling you how you get there
um
if it's not specified you have some some
notion of a default area for example
whatever the user is logged in under
this that is used as the area but at
every system you have some natural idea
as to what that's going to mean for the
for the default area when no area is
mentioned and when it is mentioned then
it might even be partially defaulted and
so on there's there's a variety of
conventions for that
um
let's talk about fonts also here I've
got
a format file here I've got a
paper file what if I have a font
um
f f is my is say the name of the font
then when I'm running meta find I would
have FF dot MF for The Meta font source
file
and it would produce lots of different
kinds of output it might produce FF dot
DVI if we're doing proof mode but for
and and if F dot pxl for the bit image
of the font FF dot uh
um
TFM is the one that concerns us
the tech font metric file this would
give the information to take
and uh a variety of other possible
things that
ff.chr is what we're using for files
that can be edited so that you can you
can play with the pixels yourself at low
resolution
um
okay so this idea of extension is there
and we also have the programs TF to PL
and pl to TF I'll be talking about later
today so they would so we could you
could read the fftfm file and convert
that into ff.p.o
so for for a variety of these things we
we've seen seem to see that we want a
name of a
name and then an extension telling what
uh what's class of file uh relating to
this name uh is involved
now um
slight difference is there is exists
though between font files and and these
other kinds of files because usually the
fonts are something that live
that that their home is in the system
while uh a person's paper is on his own
area
so when you specify no area for a paper
it means your own login area if you
specify no area for a font it means the
system font area if you want to use a
font that's only your own that you just
made yourself with meta font say then
you then you are supposed to really
specify your own area specifically in
the case of fonts
because if you because if you leave it
blank that's going that's going to mean
the the system font by that name unless
the unless there is no system font by
that name it would look but it would
look first for the system or so so our
and I think that we have to uh realize
that these that these are different so
Tech is is using that assumption now
that the that if the area is is blank
um get me it it means the default area
of some sort but the default for
fonts is the system fund area the
defaults for other things is the user's
logged in area
I tried one if on a file name for
where are you Arthur okay
if on a file name for a tech source file
we omit the directory and it's not a
directory classification and it's not in
our area does it look in the system area
afterwards as it used to yes yes that is
built in right now that we have a
default area to looks to look before
complaining that we couldn't find the
file at all
so it looks first on your area and then
it looks on the syst on a system area
we'll we'll see that later on in this
hour I I think I'll get to that
um
and this could be extended to to look in
several to go through a sequence of
other areas uh
before giving up and and saying I can't
find your file please give me another
name but right but right now the code
does support one one extra try on uh
after the after backslash input
um okay good point now now uh
in in the case of font files we have to
communicate the file name to the DVI
file
so after we get this after Tech has read
in the font file then the DVI file is
going to have to contain the name of
that font for communication to the
outside world
and so the name the name of the font is
given by giving its area and its name
and uh both of those are
um our our sequences of ASCII codes so
in the DVI file specification well we'll
see it later but it turns out that the
area which is usually empty for the
system fonts and the name are given as a
sequence of asci code or more precisely
Tech internal codes so that the font
name that you use comes out in a DVI
file without the extension without a tfn
without any extension whatsoever
okay now how are we going to do this I
tried once to to think of a scheme that
would Encompass all of the world's
naming conventions for five for for
files and as and then um
uh I I would parse I I would I would
parse this and I I would have a
universal uh ever except MIT I left out
MIT I had every other possible scheme of
of file naming that I that I could find
and I and then I was going to uh Define
the Syntax for this and then put it all
into a thing and then and then uh uh let
the system dependent part just just uh
or look at this or maybe even work work
on all systems well that was a failure
it didn't it couldn't be done
um so instead I I uh I said what I'm
going to do is I'm gonna I'm gonna ask
everybody to write three procedures
that are explained there in module 429
begin name more name and end name
and uh when Tech comes to the to a point
where it needs a filing for example it
has just passed uh the keyword input or
some other place we need the following
there are more than you might uh imagine
uh after fonts and so on then it will
start and it will call the procedure
begin name
suppose somebody writes input and then
after that he has a sequence of
characters C1 C2 C3 and so on after this
is after a macro expansion so Tech will
then Supply tokens to the to or what
characters actually to the to these uh
to this thing morning takes in
um uh C ASCII code uh Tech internal code
symbol as a parameter
but begin name and end name don't have
parameters okay now what what tech is
going to do yeah oh by the way this is
uh if this also returns a value so this
is a function that Returns the Boolean
value
um
Tech Will first call begin name
and then it will get the next character
of the input and
expanding macro if it was there
and uh if the if the next character is
not a is a tech primitive something like
deaf or something like that then Tech
will immediately call end name and say
that uh that we've got to the end
um if it's a blank space Tech will also
I I believe call end name right away but
if it's a character
um then it will call more name of C
and give value back true or false
more name is going to return true
if the na if if the name has uh hasn't
ended yet
um
uh as far as it knows that this just
needn't have to be the end of the name
but morning would return false if this
is definitely the end of the name and
text should stop in section should call
end name immediately afterwards
and uh so we'll keep calling more name
more name more name until we either get
to something that Tech thinks is the end
of the name or until more name says
false
Tech thinks it's the end of the name
when I get to something that isn't a
character or when I get to a blank space
so this means that for example at MIT if
the first character of the name is
um a quote mark
then more name would return true until
it got to another quote Mark in which
I'll protect that was false for example
this is a way that that the logic of
calling these three procedures would be
would be the same on all systems but the
three procedures themselves be different
now after and after uh this is all done
an end name has been called then what's
supposed to happen is that we're
supposed to have three Global variables
have been set up called Cur
IA
current name
and her
X for the area of the name and the
extension and these are string numbers
these are Pointers into text string pool
uh giving what those areas are in as a
string that could be printed out and
Print in principle
so these are these are the result of n
name will be will be those three areas
uh those three uh those three things
and they're all strings in the sense of
text strings that we talked about a
couple days ago
um if the one of the strings that you
can have in Tech is is the null string
on Pascal compilers don't always allow
in all strings but anyway um
but if the null string is is one of the
ones that Tech has in its pool and that
would be used if the area is blank and
the extension is blank so if this guy
just writes paper here it should her
name should be the string papers
carry and Cur X are blank that's the one
thing I want these least to satisfy the
other things are dependent on what you
think is is appropriate for your
particular system
so for example if this um
just you know if if this if if
um I had d e k paper here
um and I was using a top 20 system
then uh
um
the the program we call begin name begin
name would uh would would set some kind
of initialization so that it knows what
it's doing uh these three procedures
typically will communicate with among
themselves with global variables
and then I'll call more name of of of
less than more name with d more name of
e more name okay and so on morning until
I get to more name of R and then I get a
space and I wouldn't call more name
anymore I'd call end name
or or something after something besides
like a backslash input again comes right
after that then I would I would again
uh
quit
okay now
um
I want to illustrate that the program
assumes a special kind of of uh syntax
that is uh uh that is typical of other
ones but it's one that was close enough
to something I was familiar with that I
could I could do
um and and so uh the example of how to
write begin name more name and end name
in this in these sections are based on a
simple
um
uh uh simple scheme that's defined in
module 430 and here's the scheme that I
that I propose there if the name
contains a greater than sign or a colon
the file area consists of all characters
up to including the final such character
so if you had several colons several
greater thans and so on
um only the last one counts
otherwise the area is null
now after you've thrown away the area by
this rule then you look for DOT for for
Dots and if there's
if there's several dots only the first
one counts not the last but the first
one counts and then um uh that the
extension would be every character
including that first thought for to the
end otherwise the extension is known
so that's the that's the that's the uh
proposed example that's used in the in
in the uh program and it in order to
implement that I did that by having two
Global variables called the area
delimiter and the X delimiter and this
would just be a place in the string pool
where where the most recent or relevant
um uh delimiter has occurred either a
greater than sign a colon or a period so
we have uh so as
um in in our score system for example in
order for me to refer to paper I would
have to say CSD dot d e k paper and I
could I could also refer to I could also
say dot um
Tech dot two
in order to refer to version two of the
paper
in that case this would be the area
and this would be the extension
because I pick up the first period and
and I if I don't count the period that's
in there
okay now how how does more name
Implement that well it's simple it has a
pointer to the the most recent uh right
greater than sign or colon and a pointer
to periods and so it starts putting in
the string pool a left Arrow
let's see let me go give myself another
board here
so I'll have my um
area delimiter a and my x delimiter e
and initially they're null
so I put in the string pool the first
character less than minus C and an S and
a d and a period well this looks like
the X the external delimiter should be a
period because this might be the
extension coming up here now
uh d e k
and a greater than sign comes along
greater than sine says oh oh this is an
area delimiter so I'm supposed to
remember the the final greater than sign
and so that comes here also I wipe out e
at this time because though they don't
count if they're in the area part
and then it would say p-a-p-e-r
Dot
e starts the point there
if I got a colon now or something it
would wipe this out again
uh t e x
period uh now I check with this period I
check that this guy is out is is already
non-null so I don't change him again
too
and then
um end name is called now end name has
to figure out from the the fact that a
is pointing somewhere and E is pointing
somewhere that
would that this act that this string
here is supposed to really be broken
into three strings and so I think the
code does that
and it makes up three strings in the
string pull according to the conventions
of the string pool so that string start
of Cur area would be here string start
of occur name be here and string start
of correct would be here
okay
so these three programs you need to
write
uh
to do the right thing for your system
now
we also have to figure out how we're
going to open files that that are there
and Scott doesn't give us a
uh Pascal is really intended more for
a small self-contained uh
programs when it was when it was
designed but but it's all it's been
always extended now so that it's
possible to on on every Pascal I know of
to say reset
um and then you say file name
and then you have some trial variable
this is
uh in your Pascal program then you have
some way to say what file you want to
open
so let's suppose that in this that we're
working with Pascal that allows us to
put here like name of file okay paper
um uh now let's suppose that this has
this string has to be of a certain
definite length it uh depends on on
which Pascal you have as to what
happened but anyway you should be able
to specify uh the name of some file that
you want to to input to uh to the system
routine for resetting if you can't do
that
you just can't possibly use Tech because
Tech has to be able to read from files
that aren't known that uh at compile
time of the Pascal program
um
so the file variable and then we have
some extension that allows us to do this
either by some system call or some
something it's got to be possible
and it almost and it is so now what
about this string here well let's see
Tech call Tech uh when it does this uh
it assumes that this string I believe is
called name of file I should have
reviewed this this morning
but that's it name of file so we're
going to say that this parameter here is
a is a very the global variable called
name of file
and Tech is going to set that Global
variable name of file
um before it tries to to reset the file
and the system procedure that does this
is called pack file name and it's in
module 436.
pack file name
has three parameters
N A and E in this order and their string
number
which means that you know it's an
indication of the string it's text
it's text uh idea of strings
so so uh if you give it the three
strings that you found that after end
name those strings are supposed to exist
in Cur name and so on
um
and then pack file name will do it now
Tech is going to substitute its
extension though sometimes you see
that's so if Cur name for example is uh
paper
um and then Tech is going to it's going
to Output to paper dot err to paper.err
then pack file name is going to be
called with the extension part set to
string.err
so so Tech will end
similarly.dvi.fmt Tech Will generate
other calls on Pac file name for other
things
text going to manufacture combinations
of file names according to this
according to this procedure
okay now um
um
we we need uh
okay so pack file name does that and and
uh puts into the global variable name of
file the uh uh the thick the thing in
the in the correct format now I don't
know if anybody here has a 10x system uh
one of the old deck operating systems
but in that case uh in order to call
reset on on one pascal compiler that I
know of you had to have and you had to
have two parameters in for name of file
you've had to have a string and and a
Pippin and the Pippin was given in what
they called six bit code which was a
pack which was a curiously packed 36-bit
word full of six bit uh numbers and uh
it's the only way the operating system
would accept it
um and and so the reset procedure had
three parameters and and so this pack
file name procedure on such a on such a
version of Pascal would would have to
set two things one of them would require
a
calculation of a six bit code from the
extension in some in some grungy manner
but this was uh this is necessary and
I'm sure that that uh that there are
even weirder systems in existence that
are going to need this but that's what
why I put this up as a separate routine
and don't consider it the system
independent
um further you further on the better
Pascal compiler that I'm using now on
sale system I have we put the area last
you know instead of first and so pack
file name is certainly different on this
machine and is on other so anyway I hope
you got that one now there's a there's
another program you need also besides
Pac file name which is packed buffered
name and this one is
um
not as as as as clean
uh it
but it's unfortunately necessary because
sometimes we
um we're going to have to be getting
a file name
um
before the tech has been able to set up
its strings
you see when text starts out
uh and we've got a virgin version of
tech
it has to read in its strings it doesn't
know any strings it can't use the his
idea of Cur area Cur name and Cur extent
extension at all because strings don't
exist yet we have to get the format file
so so uh the the user is based on the
user's input we'll know whether there's
a format file or not
um or or to use a standard format file
like basic
um and we haven't got strings yet so I
have to do something special there and
get the and get the name right out of
the buffer
and so
uh this routine is got different kind of
parameters
and um uh it's and it's the first
parameter is called a small number
a small number is um 0 to 63. uh
it's generally even smaller
um
uh and then A and B are also parameters
to this thing but a um n and a don't
don't match the n and a there so it
probably wasn't a good a good idea
um but these are integers but also
typically small
and the idea is
that uh
that that we're going to manufacture
name of file from something in the
buffer instead of using the nice begin
name more name and name conventions that
we had there and this has to be done in
the following way
um
I have a string called Tech format
defaults
and I Illustrated it there in in module
as being something like this Tech
formats
dot uh basic Tech
basic format excuse me
some string that indicates the default
file name that you would use the default
name of file that you would use if the
the you if if there is no specified file
name given
um
and uh what's what pack buffer name is
supposed to do
it's supposed to take the first n
characters of this string
and then it's supposed to take
characters A to B out of the buffer
buffer is something we use for input
buffers yeah for for input from the
terminal so buffer a through b
um inclusive
and then the last four characters of
this string
Dot fmt
that's the way that thing is defined
right now
this is a procedure pack buffer name
that has to be used when Tech is really
bootstrapping itself to get going at the
beginning of a job it's not allowed to
call error messages yet because the
error routine isn't isn't uh workable
error routine needs strings
so this is way at the beginning when
when Tech has uh is just being born
every time when it's been if it's been
loaded
and that is uh messy but there's no
other way I mean we had to do something
at this point to get to get everything
going
so uh that routine is called only in
module 441.
it's called three times though
um and what have what we have what
happens is this suppose somebody calls
Tech
and and and he's running a virgin
version of tech which means that it's
not any Tech it's the it's the one that
it's the one that's used for production
um but uh it could be used if it doesn't
have any format pre-loaded into it
so the next thing that you that person
writes is the name of the format
uh so if if uh the next thing a person
writes is amstec for example then it
should look for amstec.fmt uh in in some
system format area or it's or in the
users format area
um
and then you could say paper after that
and then you would you it would be the
paper that you're um bacteria this would
be a way to call it if you can't support
getting this on your command line this
would be given to the double star prompt
that you would get at right afterwards
um but in any case the first thing would
be the format file it that's to be read
in
well what so it's sitting in the buffer
because this has come this has somehow
gotten into the buffer and Tech will
know where this thing starts in some
position in the buffer some some
subscript in the buffer and it'll know
where it ends in the in the buffer it
looks for a blank space for this purpose
I believe yeah
now so format names should be given at
least that's the assumption that that
we're making here that and seems to be
reasonable for all the systems we knew
of
um okay now
uh so what is this uh module 441 do
um it looks first to see whether he's
got a backslash
this might also be relaxed or some some
other primitive saying that uh I don't
want you know I I don't want you to
input any file any any Source about that
because if it's a backslash like this
then we're going to assume we got the
basic format that we're going to this
default one
we're going to come in so this quote is
not a backslash
then we look for this
um
uh Dot fmt
pretty sure that's exactly if you first
try without the system file area
and with the dot fmt so we call pack
buffered name
on this whole on this thing but with n
equals zero so we don't pick up any of
the of the first part
and so it'll look you look for amste x
dot fmt on the user's uh on the users
area
it doesn't find that
then
uh it tries next
with the system file area so then it
sets n equals some number that's the
number of strings to use it's called Uh
format default links
format default length is in and the next
time so it'll try for Tech dot formats
amsterex should find it then
but if it doesn't then it pulls out all
the stops and uses this whole format
default name
since A and B to something like zero one
and zero or something so you won't pick
up anything off of the user's area and
that would be the normal case the normal
case is that there's no specific format
given here it just has the name of the
person's paper and so it won't so it
would pick up the system area and the
user wouldn't have to know that there
was even a chance to to specify another
format at that point at that point Yeah
question
yes why do you use the back press the
target there
sorry why why are you in the backsplash
they're the kind of safeguards which may
not be the backslash anymore yeah the uh
uh
the the
backslash is always
assumed to be an escape character it's
the only character that whose type is
known but in the in in Tech 82 we are
starting out assuming that backslash is
an escape character as a as an
assumption this means really the code
whose internal Tech code is is uh
octa-136 it it doesn't have to be
visibly a backslash but it has to be the
character that's internal code is one is
I mean uh
at the Code table initially
um uh understands uh letters
um and that and that backslash
uh this other idea that we had in Tech
uh uh the present Tech that the first
character you type in is going to be
your Escape character uh it sounded good
to us at the time in 1977 but it's
caused no end of confusion ever since
and and uh and uh uh there were great
size of relief when I when I told my
group that we were gonna assume that we
we know uh that it's going to be
backslashed uh one of the one of the
most funny examples of this in the other
case of tech was when the a novice user
approached Tech it gave the gave the
prompt of asterisk and uh
the type in was paper
seemed a reasonable thing to do compared
to other systems that were there well so
P was the backslash character
um uh P was the Escape character so then
it had a macro PA because this this
Escape character terminated agency well
that's backslash a that's a an accent
and so I said whoa you have to define a
font first this was a very scary first
encounter with tech
um now now this is going to work and and
uh it's uh and we found that I think
most users wanted that so that so if if
you have some other character that
that's going to be the standard Escape
at your system you just publicize that
in the manual and everybody will be glad
to use it but this this changeability of
the Escape character
um was not a win
I'm not winning IBS or dropping it
or if somebody says Tech uh so so also
the manual is going to say how do you
run Tech and so it's going to say well
you give the name of the file that you
want or if you or if you're going to do
some simple experiment with it you say
backslash relax
you could say backslash input paper
wouldn't hurt
but if your first if the first thing
that you type in is not a backslash it
assume it it essentially implies that it
was backslash input
and it's the first thing you type in was
not a for the name of a format it
assumes that it's going to be the
default format
we've rest we wrestled around with lots
of different possible strategies and
this one turned out to be the one that
seemed to to satisfy all the
requirements as well as anything I think
it's going to work well
um okay that's so pack buffered name is
is this routine that has to be used in
order to get the uh the the format uh
going at the beginning it's only used in
that one place and uh and so if you have
to do something special for your system
uh you just have to do it at that at
that time
okay now let's see
um
module 442 talks about something that
we'd like to do if you can but it's not
necessary to uh to make a change here
that is uh
uh figure out what what actual if what's
the actual full name
um of the file that you have just opened
yes so if I for example if I'm writing
paper.dvi
um it'd be nice if if I had a system
call I would say that this is actually
paper.dvi versions
28th and so that on my on my transcript
file and it will tell me that I have
just written this one dot version 28 so
that I can tell which which it was my
transcript file will have a date and
time on it if we've been able to
implement that part but it was also nice
to correlate that with the actual file
that you've written out so there are
calls it's called jiffins on top 20 and
there's uh various ways to get at uh
hidden things on the sale system and I'm
sure Bax has different calls this other
operating system usually have a way to
say what is the exact full file name
that I have just opened you have a
question yes if you have a system that
doesn't allow multiple versions of yeah
an automatic scratching of old versions
or uh that's what we have yeah that's
what we have in fact even our system
that allows multiple versions uh they
tend to fill up the disk very fast and
we and
um and uh if you're paying for it you
you pretty soon set that as your default
although uh I have seen
uh in other places where I wasn't paying
for it like when I used the free
services at Xerox uh uh sometimes I I
had run up about 210 versions of
errors.temp at one point uh before I ran
out of memory and and had to had to go
back to my recent version but uh you
know they they accumulate very fast and
it's nice to have but it's a luxury
um and uh the system that I use every
day uh
um I I get by with only the most recent
version and on the
only twice a year do I
go through fits of anxiety because I
just clobbered it
that's something that I that I needed
um
anyway if you're used to working on that
kind of a system you you learn how to
protect yourself against disasters most
of the time yeah
uh but I I don't know just not everybody
will agree with these things anyway we
got this make name String function which
which is supposed to take either the the
file that you've just opened
um uh and find out what it is oh uh and
and so we give the make name String I
have three functions defined there a
make name String for an alpha file B
make name String for a byte file and W
make name stream for a word file only
because
only because in Pascal I had to have a
type associated with a file name
unless I'm writing a system procedure
and these would return a string that
gives me the the full uh the full file
name
and including like in our system it
would tell me that I found one on the
system area
uh if if that was the one that was
actually being input
um if you if you can't do that you could
generate it just from name of file
but you're supposed to generate a string
like this a couple of times for for
error messages and uh for for for uh
historical records that Tech uh makes
um uh I guess I should mention Alpha
file is a file
that corresponds to text uh like um like
a source uh like your dot Tex files that
you're inputting a b byte file is a is a
file of 8-bit bytes like a TFM file or a
DVI file and the word files are the dot
fmt files the format files that we that
are made out of memory words
that we store and retrieve for uh
initializing Tech
thank you
is there some particular Global that
make name String is supposed to return
the name of make name String returns a
string number
and it's given the file a file variable
as its input so so the idea is if F
represents a Channel or some you know if
F represents it a channel in in uh
deck jargon is similar to uh file
variable in Pascal jargon whatever has
just been opened on that file
um
uh we should uh we should pre we should
create a string in text string pool and
return the number of that string
so will you always be calling one of the
typed versions of this is that what just
yeah I always call one of the type
versions right
um and by looking in the index you'll
see that it that each it's only called
about twice you know but there are those
times when I when I when I do want to
know the name of the file that I just
opened for example when I when somebody
says input paper uh at in the sales
system and we we saw that on in the demo
the other day so what actually came out
of left parenthesis uh saying I'm
starting to read a file and then it said
paper was capitalized paper dot TDX
that was the default extension applied
at that time left bracket
um
uh I think whatever I was logged in
under I think it was past dek
was was there that was printed off and
that full name was supplied by my system
dependent uh a make name String
the uh
this code starting in module 444 here is
supposed to be independent system
independent uh not requiring any any uh
changes by you guys and uh so it
summarized the way we should have done
this
begin name more name and name this is
the driver that calls that
uh they're also the driver is also
called somewhere else
where where it pulls the characters out
of the buffer
um
uh when you're declaring fonts that's in
the prompt file name routine which again
is supposed to be Machining pen so the
rest of this section uh is it tells
about the things that that ought to work
everywhere uh a few of them might maybe
might be marked system depend but I
don't think so so the uh the critical
problems about the timing of these
things fitting it in with all of Tech's
input and output routines getting it to
going in the right place I think I've
done that in a system independent way
all you have to do is is these routines
that are defined without knowing much of
the logic of tech you just have to these
are system uh system problems they tried
to factor out the the uh the tech
algorithms the thing specific Tech into
and and leave you just with uh
comparatively simple tasks begin name
morning and name that don't depend on on
the fact that Tech is also writing
paragraphs and and uh has has even even
that you don't have to know that Tech is
going to be uh prompting the user
um to give you another one if you can't
find the other one I mean that logic can
prompt file name
is supposed to work in all versions of
tech you want to look at proper file
name I mean that's module 448 it um it
has two parameters one of them is is
descriptive of what kind of a file it's
it it wants and the other one is is the
default extension that it would apply
and it
it uh it either says I can't find file
paper.tech or something like that or it
says
um
I can't write on file paper see print
file name is a is a system dependent
procedures that I neglected to mention
it must have been in one of those
it must have been yeah yes yes my module
435 I didn't mention you need a a
procedure that takes three strings as
input and it and it prints them out
as the name that might have produced and
that's such a simple procedure short one
I forgot to mention it so print file
name is one you've got to write also
if unless it's the same as the one there
um so it prints out the name that it
can't find
and then it um
uh if the extension is dot Tex it shows
the context of the message in the case
of save
or send files and in the case of input
files uh it was appropriate to show uh
to show the uh where the file name
appeared in the person's input but in
the other cases this was a file name
that was manufactured behind the scenes
and the context wouldn't make sense so
so this uh that's why it doesn't show
context in any other cases but show
context is a subroutine that prints out
these two-line
indications of where you are in in your
Source valve on on an error message
then it'll say please type another s
please type another input file name
please type another output file name
something like that
it looks next to see an interaction
that's one of the things that Tech has
is a level it's it's four levels of
interaction there's batch mode non-stop
mode scroll mode and error stop mode and
if the interaction level is either batch
mode or non-stop mode then you're not
supposed to ever mention a file name
that couldn't be found so your job is
aborted at that time batch mode for
example is intended for overnight
running and if it can't find the file at
that time
you're dead there's nothing to
substitute for
um but otherwise if you were in scroll
motor air stop mode then you get a
chance to input a new file name
in the first two cases it would have at
least told you what it couldn't find
Before Time oh now let's see um so then
it clears the terminal clear terminal
means uh uh a show in case the user has
been typing ahead uh cancel what he's
been typing ahead
um
that's a system dependent thing you'd
have to do some people think they
they're they know what's going to go on
and they they start typing away and and
save themselves some time but uh in air
like this occurs
um then they don't want uh what they
typed ahead to be considered the new
file name so we clear that we prompt
them
um uh and scan the file aim in a buffer
which is the next module that that is
another call on begin name or name and
end name
um
uh The Prompt input routine gets
something from the terminal and puts in
the buffer
uh after we've got the file name in it
and we've got an empty extension we we
use e as the default for empty extension
we pack the current name
uh that's a macro call explained there
that calls pack file name in with the
current name current area incur
extension so that's the logic there in
problem and that logic you shouldn't
have to change uh that's logic was the
you know it's something that knows about
the rest of tech the other routines that
I've mentioned don't have to
um yeah one more thing I want to make
one more point I want to make before I
before we close before I forget it and
that is this reset procedure here that
opens a new file
it's not only supposed to be something
that that is able to open another file
but it's supposed to be it's it's not
supposed to give us a system error
message in case it it couldn't find the
file
um
and otherwise you will have to change
text logic so I want to explain that if
the or similarly rewrite
is another one where where you have a
file variable
and and a name of file
uh where you're trying to open uh or get
get ready to write on a certain uh file
name that you've generated in your
program
now
um
these I I have procedures called open
um a open B open for Alpha file opening
and B file opening but uh and they're
going to return true or false based on
whether or not they were successful in
opening this but when they call reset
and rewrite you you need procedures
reset and rewrite that are going to let
you test that are going to let you know
whether that file was there or not
and the way uh the way Hendrix Pascal
does it I think is the best solution and
that is it you look at eof at the end
after you've done a reset and if and uh
if eof
is um it's called it's it's false then
you were successful of on opening this
file you if you found in file for input
because you're not at the end of the
file and for for output if eof is true
you're successful you uh you've
successfully gotten that file ready for
output
um but if the opposite holds so if you
try to reset and you found that you that
eof was true this is what uh this this
this says oh the file wasn't there and
uh if you tried to rewrite and you get a
false eof you're not an end to file this
is your clue that the file wasn't there
now if you do if on the other hand if
you're using a pascal runtime system
that's real smart and it says uh oh yes
I couldn't open this file so I so I'm
going to ask the user for filing myself
well then the user might get an
inscrutable error message that isn't
tied into the text system uh but then
the op but but that's not the worst of
it the worst of it is that the um
um that the reset procedure will always
return this condition and so Tech will
always think no matter what the user
typed that it was okay
um so for example you you misspell your
file name
um or uh then uh it appears in the error
message uh you know say you you didn't
know what you were supposed to do you
typed a question mark and um Tech
um will uh will then um uh um call to
open the file question mark.tech
for input okay well the uh the the
Pascal runtime routine will try to open
question mark detect it won't find it
and it says you know it'll say something
like uh file uh uh not found question
mark dot Tech uh new file name what
should it be so you type in a new file
name oh yes paper dot Tech
and it finds it but then Tech is gonna
look at this question mark and think it
was okay so it's going to try question
mark.err for the transcript file and
it's going to try question mark.dvi for
the awkward file because because Tech
didn't have any indication that anything
went wrong
um and so you're going to get have to
type all those three in in also
afterwards
um so so it's so we want to use a
version of reset we want to make sure
that this reset gives gives the
information and the chance to make error
messages to to Tech and that and doesn't
try to do it all itself if not you have
to think of some other way around it
okay uh now so that finishes our our
first hour in five minutes
um Arthur is it quick uh yes uh on on
some systems that do that you might
still be able to find out the name of
the file uh that was opened oh there
would be a way out probably but uh but
you will have to to have to get into uh
some of the logic of tech in that case
and and and and and work a little harder
the right now it's set up it's set up
for under the assumption that we are
able to have a procedure open that will
um that we'll be able to return true or
false as to whether it was successful
open or not and that and uh we're trying
to give a good indication of uh of what
files we couldn't uh we couldn't open
since you asked the question it reminded
me you you would ask earlier a question
about uh about the tech uh the standard
area and what happens when you type
backslash input so if you want to look
that up that's module 454 uh where the
um uh where the file for input is
actually opened and the calls unpack
file name with a tech area that's a a
macro defined to be the standard area
used to be used in case you have an area
that commonly uh commonly used input
files appear okay
okay I believe the same this exactly the
same input systems are going to be used
in meta fonts so once you solve this
problem for Tech you'll also have a
sulfur metaphon next year your job will
be a lot easier
okay uh have a nice break and see you
again at 11 o'clock
foreign